في المتابعه من خان يونس مراسل الجزيره
مؤمن الشرافي اهلا بك مؤمن نتابع معك ابرز
التطورات الميدانيه واين تركز القصف
الاسرائيلي في الساعات
الاخيره نعم عبد السلام خلال الساعات
الاخيره كثفت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه وايضا المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
من قصفها لمختلف المناطق في مدينه خان
يونس وتحديدا الاحياء التي تقع في وسط
المدينه اسفرت هذه الغارات وعمليات القصف
الاسرائيلي حتى هذه اللحظه ومنذ ساعات
الصباح عن استشهاد اربعه فلسطينيين وصلوا
الى مجمع ناصر الطبي بينهم امراه بالاضافه
الى وصول عشرات الاصابات نتيجه تواصل
القصف المدفعي تحديدا من قبل الاليات
والدبابات الاسرائيليه المتمركزه في عدد
من المناطق والمحاور التي تشهد اشتباكات
مسلحه عنيفه بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قبل قليل كتائب
الشهيد عز الدين القسام اعلنت عن استهداف
تجمعا للاليات العسكريه ولجن الاحتلال في
المحور الجنوبي الشرقي من مدينه خان يونس
بقذائف الهاون وكذلك سرايا القدس استهدفت
اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه تتمركز في منطقه
المحطه ومناطق اخرى قريبه من وسط مدينه
خانيونس بقذائف
الهاون الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي لا
يفارق اجواء مدينه خانيونس على وجه
التحديد وكذلك طائرات الاستطلاع التي تحلق
على ارتفاعات منخفضه و تستهدف جميع من
يحاول من سكان مدينه خانيونس الوصول الى
مناطقهم تحديدا في وسط المدينه عبر
الطائرات المصيره التي تفتح نيران اسلحتها
اتجاه المواطنين الذين يصلون الى تلك
المنطقه اليات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
حتى هذه اللحظه لم تصل الى قلب مدينه خنين
س وتحديدا منطقه البلد وهي المنطقه التي
كانت معروفه بحيويتها ومنطقه تجاريه وايضا
منطقه سكنيه خالصه في وسط قطاع غزه تحديدا
كانت الغارات الاسرائيليه وكذلك القصف
المدفعي اكثر عنفا واكثر حده على مختلف
المناطق وتحديدا في مخيم البريج وايضا
مخيم النصيرات ومخيم المغازي الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه استهدفت منذ ساعات
الصباح وحتى هذه اللحظه ثلاث منازل منزلين
في مخيم النصيرات واخر في منطقه الحكر في
دير البلح اصفرت هذه الغارات التي استهدفت
منازل ماهوله بالسكان ودون سابق انذار عن
سقوط عدد من الشهداء وايضا وصول عشرات
الاصابات الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى المصادر
الطبيه في المشوى وصفت حاله بعض الجرحى
بال الخطيره ومن بين الجرحى بطبيعه الحال
نساء واطفال استهدفتهم الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه داخل منازلهم كما طلب جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من سكان عدد من
المناطق في مخيم المغازي وايضا منطقه
ابراج عين جالوت جنوب مخيم النصيرات
باخلاء هذه المنطقه مدعيا انها منطقه
عمليات عسكريه وكان جيش الاحتلال استهدف
بعدد من القذائف
الصاروخيه منطقه ابراج عين جالوت ما ادى
الى الحاق اضرار ماديه في هذه المنطقه
المعروفه بكثافتها السكانيه وايضا اصاب
اصابه عدد من سكان تلك المنطقه بالاضافه
الى الاشتباكات التي تدور وتزداد وتيرتها
في شرق مخيم البريج بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
التي تحاول منذ بدء التوغل البري في منطقه
وسط غزه الدخول والسيطره على المخيم وسط
مقاومه عنيفه من قبل مختلف الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وفي مقدمتها كتائب الشهيد عز
الدين القسام